everybody I'm playing with a little bit  of editing on garyvaynerchuk.com  so bear with me but here it goes you  know sometimes you know thinking about  new stuff to say and I want the quality  content to be good and not waste your  time and I wanted to come up with  something lightweight that helped me  kind of communicate my thoughts on a  daily basis cuz I want to be more Givi  calm which is not a URL Garriga calm and  so I'm going to start with something  called frown up frown down so this is  how it's basically gonna work coming  forward you're gonna see a very very  short video for me that's going to go  like this  and then you'll see something which you  just did and then you'll see me do this  and you see something like you just I  hope you enjoy